Speaker 1: All right, so I want to go over
a couple of these stories which have now become
all too common, where some anthrax person,
some covid Denyer, some antifascist, whatever,
ends up getting sick and dying of coronavirus.
And one of these stories I know Ferrand did
while I was gone, but I want to give my take
on it.
And I think there's quite a bit to say.
These are not like fun, happy stories.
They're not funny stories for me.
It's not.
I mean, listen, you guys know, I don't take
pleasure in the death of of folks who just
fell for for bad information.
But we can't ignore the fact that especially
when they change their mind on the vaccine,
once they get sick and people hear that it
can be a cautionary tale and it may actually
have some impact in getting getting more people
to go ahead and get vaccinated.
So let's start with the first one.
This is a story of H. Scott Appellee, a Texas
Republican official who mocked the covid pandemic
five days before dying of the virus.
OK, H. Scott Apley, The Daily Beast writes,
a Republican official from Texas who regularly
espoused anti vaccine anti mask views online
has died from covid-19 five days after posting
a meme on Facebook question ating question
ating questioning the wisdom of getting inoculated
against covid Dickinsons, City Council member
and State Republican Executive Committee member
H. Scott Apley, 45 years old, not 65 plus
not seventy five.
Eighty five, the way many Republicans like
to say.
Forty five year old age Scott Appellee died
in a local hospital around three a.m. Wednesday
morning, according to a Go Fund Me page set
up to help his family with expenses.
Now, I'm going to get to that in a moment
as well.
He was admitted to the facility in Galveston
on Sunday with pneumonia like symptoms hooked
up to a ventilator as his condition worsened.
His wife was also infected.
Texas Republican Party Chairman Matt Renaldi
said, please join me in lifting the Apley
family up in prayer.
Hmm.
See, instead of praying now, what about vaccinating
before?
Is that crazy?
Is that a crazy reaction to have now the prayer
going on to say we will miss Scott deeply,
but find comfort in knowing he's at peace
in the arms of our savior?
You find comfort in that.
What about the fact that he could have been
vaccinated and would have been very unlikely
to see this happen?
What about that part?
The opposite of comfort is what that should
be.
The announcement did not mention that applies.
Death was covid related.
Apley is a staunch conservative and devout
Christian.
But based on his social media activity, Apley
didn't believe covid was going to affect him
or his family.
In May, Apley posted an invitation for a mask
burning being held at a bar in Cincinnati,
commenting, I wish I lived in the area.
A couple of weeks earlier, he posted a news
article about giveaways and incentives meant
to encourage people to get vaccinated.
Writing Disgusting Appellee also railed against
so-called vaccine passports, which restrict
high risk activities such as indoor dining
to the fully vaccinated.
Recently, he suggested mask mandates in Germany
were akin to Naziism.
And when former Baltimore Health Commissioner
Leana Wen celebrated good news about the Pfizer
vaccine efficacy, a seemingly outraged Apple
called her an absolute enemy of a free people.
You can go.
It's all the same stuff in Facebook posts,
Appellee wrote.
If businesses start allowing customers and
employees go mask free only with voluntarily
providing their vaccination record, presumably
not a hip, a misspelled violation, wouldn't
that basically involve.
We can't even understand a word this guy was
writing.
What a mess.
So listen, what are the takeaways here?
I'm not happy this guy died, but if his death
serves to get some anti vaccine is vaccinated,
it will not be totally in vain, although it
is a senseless death, which almost certainly
not one hundred percent, but almost certainly
could have been prevented with a vaccine.
So take away No one.
We have something, the vaccine which makes
you really unlikely to get super sick and
die of covid.
Now there's data coming out about Breakthru
deaths, right?
We're learning that we're probably all heading
towards third doses.
We'll talk about that tomorrow.
Big announcement expected probably today.
We're learning that efficacy wanes over time,
but it's still a very powerful tool for making
you unlikely to be hospitalized and die.
That's take away No.
One.
Now, some people still will die, right?
Like with flu, with colds, sometimes in a
planet of seven billion people, things that
don't normally cause a problem.
Statistically, a very small number, but still
a percentage will cause a problem and people
will die, but most won't when they are vaccinated.
It's the best tool we have in choosing not
to take advantage of it is absurd.
Now, the Go Fund Me page, I mentioned that
they have a go fund me.
They talk about personal responsibility.
They choose not to get vaccinated, they still
expect to be taken care of at the hospital
and then they or their families beg for money
for health care, which almost certainly is
not money they would need because they didn't
get vaccinated.
Had they gotten vaccinated, they probably
wouldn't need that money.
That is not personal responsibility.
And that's another aspect.
Earlier in the show, I talked about, you know,
the stated principles for lots of these people.
They're not deeply held beliefs.
They're just what they think they can say
now to get what they want out of society or
out of a government or out of people in their
lives.
And the principles are abandoned as soon as
it's no longer convenient for them.
Let's now talk about another one of these
stories.
Sadly,